l'un des premiers visages de la campagne
législative dans la 5e circonscription
des yvelines est connu conseillère
municipale de sartrouville
vice-président de la région
ile-de-france et porte parole de valérie
pécresse dans sa campagne pour la
présidentielle
alexandra du blanche a été investi par
les républicains c'est une candidature
où je vais porter aussi ce projet pour
la france 2 valérie pécresse et dans un
territoire auquel je suis très attaché
puisque j'y vis mes enfants ils sont nés
j'y suis effectivement adjointe au maire
de sartrouville j'ai le soutien des
maires de sartrouville de montesson du
mesnil-le-roi et de nombreux élus un
scrutin qui pourrait être 100% féminin
du moins pour le second tour pas encore
déclaré la deuxième candidate pourrait
être la députée sortante et président de
la commission des lois il ya une brune
privé l'élu la république en marche
préfère pour le moment se consacrer au
terrain et aux travaux parlementaires en
cours aujourd'hui le temps est venu de
l'exercice de mon mandat les français et
singulièrement les habitants des
yvelines ne comprendrait pas que je sois
en train ou déjà dumont positionné pour
le mandat suivant il souhaitait des
hommes et des femmes politiques c'est le
message qu'ils nous en riant 2010 elle
qui soit pleinement mobilisé pour le
mandat qu on la confie en 2017 si elles
broutent iv et est élu et près de 59%
des voix elle remportait la 5e
circonscription face à jacques milliard
alors investi par les républicains le
maire de maisons laffitte s'est déclaré
candidat en novembre dernier